มี
สติอีกสวัสดีค่ะกิ๊บสวัสดีครับครูหญิงกิน
น้ำก่อนไหม
ถามเลยมีแต่กาแฟ
กาแฟกาแฟ Starbucks หรือเปล่าวันนี้ไม่
ใช่ค่ะวันนี้ไม่ไม่ใช่กาแฟสตาร์บัคนะคะ
กาแฟจำไม่ได้แล้วอ่ะร้านไหน
แต่ก็โอเคเป็นกาแฟตอนเช้าใครไปดื่มกาแฟ
เย็นนะ
โอเคสวัสดีนักเรียนทุกคนด้วยใช่ค่ะสวัสดี
ค่ะเดี๋ยวเราเขียนวันที่ก่อนแล้วกันนะยาย
ครับ
กางเกงคนอีกวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วัน
เสาร์ครับ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
23 ครับเดือนอะไรคะเดือนกรกฎาคม
เมื่อปีพศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 ขับค่ะปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2
022 หากค่ะแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงแล้วคะ
ครูนี้ตอนนี้ครับเมืองที่คุณเล็กอยู่
เนี่ยเวลา 8 โมง
28 นาทีน
อ้าวนะครับค่ะตอนเช้าเนาะ
แล้วเมืองที่คุยอิ๋งอยู่กี่โมงแล้วครับ
เหมือนที่คุยหญิงอยู่เนี่ย 9:00 น 28
นาทีค่ะ
ตอนเช้าเหมือนกันนะคะก็เร็วกว่าครูเล็ก 1
ชั่วโมงโอเคครับ
เกาะคุณก็สบายดีนะผู้หญิงก็สบายดีนะคะถึง
แม้ว่าอะไร
ก็
ไม่ได้มีอะไรนะไม่ได้เจ็บคอไม่ได้ไม่สบาย
น่ะสบายดี ok  ok ได้ได้กางเกงก็วีดีโอ
นี้นะคะผู้หญิงก็จะมีเรื่องมาเล่าให้นัก
เรียนฟังจริงๆก็เป็นนิทานนะเป็นนิทานนะคะ
เป็นนิทานของ
อ่าพี่น้องปริมที่ว่าเยอรมันไว้นิทาน
เยอรมันน้องครีมคุณนี้กลับไม่ได้เคยได้
ยิน
ไม่เคยได้คือได้ยินได้ยินแค่ชื่อเหมือน
กันแต่มันเป็นเหมือนกับเป็นซีรีส์สารั่ง
ที่เกี่ยวกับพวกเอ่อพวก Monster พวกปีศาจ
พวกนั้นมากกว่าที่ชื่อกริม
เค้าจะเป็นคุณอิ๊กรู้จักอันแฮนเซลแอนด์
เกรเทลใช่ไหมพี่น้อง
เธอเคยได้ยินแต่
ไม่รู้ว่าคือใครเธออันนี้เป็นตัวละครหรือ
ว่าจากนิทานของพี่น้องกริมที่ว่าน่าจะ
เป็นเวอร์ชั่นที่ดังมากๆเป็นนิทานที่น่า
กลัวนะปกตินะคะที่พี่น้องเป็นเขียนน่ะค่ะ
แต่ว่าเรื่องที่ครูหญิงจะมาเล่าวันนี้
เนี่ยไม่ได้น่ากลัวไม่ได้น่ากลัวขนาดนั้น
เป็นเรื่องธรรมดานะคะก็เป็นเรื่องเกี่ยว
กับคือมีผู้ชาย 1 คนนะคะคือผู้ชายคนนี้นะ
คะเขาเนี่ยอยู่กับภรรยาก็คือมีภรรยาแต่
ไม่มีลูกนะ
แล้วก็บ้านที่เขาอยู่เนี่ยนะคะเป็น
กระท่อมเก่าๆแบบนี้คุณทางแล้วไปเปิดให้ดู
นะคะ
พี่ๆก็น่าจะได้นะกระท่องเก่าๆโอเคครับอ่า
อยู่กระท่อมเก่าๆนะครับเพราะว่าจ่ายค่ะก็
ผู้ชายคนนี้นะคะเขาก็มี
อาชีพเป็นชาวประมงไม่ชอบประมูลโอเคเข้า
ประมงก็คือออกไปหาปลาใช่ไหมครับออกทะเล
เออใส่แล้วก็ไปเจาะกลับกว่าคือถ้าเป็นตอน
นั้นก็จะไปแบบตกปลาไหมพี่ก็ไม่รู้เหมือน
กันนะก็บอกว่า
แป๊บนึงนะเราเดี๋ยวเราติดต่อก็ผิดกันแล้ว
นะ
อ๋ออ๋อก็ไม่ตอบจริงๆ
ก็มบอกเขาใช่ก็ถ้าเป็นสมัยก่อนก็จะเป็น
เหมือนจะตกปลาขับมากกว่าที่เป็นสิ่งที่
เป็นแหลบจะไปเยอะๆครับสายเพราะว่าเขาก็
บอกว่าทุกๆวันเนี่ยนะคะผู้ชายอันนี้เนี่ย
เขาก็จะออกไปตกปลาแล้วก็คืออย่างที่คุณ
บอกว่าครอบครัวนี้เนี่ยกระท่อมก็เก่าก็
แปลว่าเป็นคนยากจนใช่ไหมคะไม่ค่อยแบบไม่
ค่อยมีเงินก็คือนายก็ทุกวันเนี่ยเวลาที่
ผู้ชายออกไปตกปลาก็ซื้อตกปลามาเเล้วก็เอา
มากินกินเองก็อาจจะไปขายด้วยแต่ก็เอามา
กินเองนะคะก็เขาบอกว่ามีอยู่วันหนึ่งผู้
ชายคนเนี้ยหรือว่าชาวประมงคนนี้นะคะเขาก็
ออกไปตกปลาปกติในทุกๆวันแต่ว่าในช่วง
อาทิตย์นี้มันก็เหมือนว่าออกไปก็กลับบ้าน
มาก็ไม่ได้ปลาชอบเพราะวันรุ่งขึ้นออกไปตก
ปลากลับบ้านมาก็ไม่มีปลา
อาจจะตกทุกวันจนปลาออกลูกไม่ทันหรือเปล่า
หรือจริงๆอาจจะเป็นจะเพราะถ้าไม่ใช่ช่วง
ไม่ใช่ฤดูตกปลาหรือเปล่าปลาที่ตรงนั้นอาจ
จะว่ายไปที่อื่น
ก็อาจจะได้นะคะก็นั่นแหละค่ะเดี๋ยวเขาไป
งานทุกวันทุกวันกลับบ้านมาภรรยาก็แบบไม่
ได้ปลาอยู่แล้วหรอ
หงุดหงิดนิดหน่อยนะคะก็มีวันหนึ่งอะไรนะ
อะไรยาหิวหรือยังหิว
ถ้าเธอไม่ได้ตามาเนี่ยปลาที่เราตกเอาไว้
อาทิตย์ที่แล้วอ้ะมันจะหมดแล้วนะเออ
แล้วทำยังไงล่ะสายผู้ชายก็แบบเราแต่ก็
โอเคออกไปอีกก็ออกไปวันนี้นะคะก็
เหมือนกับว่าวันนี้โชคดีได้ปลา
แต่ครูนี้คะราคาที่ชาวประมงเนี่ยจับหรือ
ว่าตบได้วันนี้เนี่ยมันมีปลาธรรมดาไงคะ
โอเคเป็นมาลัยครับเขาบอกว่ามันเป็นลาสี
ทอง
ใส่ค่ะทองนะไม่ใช่ปลาทองใช่ไหม
ปลาทองไม่อยู่ทะเลนะคะ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
เฮ้ยท้อแต่นี่เป็นปลาสีทอง
ช้าใช่แล้วก็เป็นปลาชีพพูดได้โอเคเกินให้
ตัวแบบไม่ใหญ่มากนั้นสัตว์ตัวประมาณนี้นะ
คะไม่รู้ความยาวนะความยาวนะคะครับ
ปลาเนี่ยก็พูดกับชาวประมงปลาก็บอกว่า
เนี่ยฉันเนี่ยนะคะฉันเนี่ยนะคะฉันเนี่ยนะ
เป็นเจ้าชายเป็นปลาเจ้าชาย x  little
mermaid หรือเปล่านะคะอ่ะ
มีปลาช่องชายนะไม่ใช่ปลาธรรมดาซึ่ง
ชาวประมงเนี่ยเขาน่าจะเป็นคนที่ใจดีอ่ะ
ค่ะเพราะว่าพอเขาเห็นว่าเออลาเป็นเจ้าชาย
แล้วปลาก็พูดได้เขาก็เลยไม่เอาปลาที่ตก
ได้เนี่ยกลับบ้านเอาเขาก็ปล่อยปล่อยปลา
เนี่ยลงแม่น้ำไปลงทะเลไปปล่อยปลาลงทะเลใบ
ครับ
ตาก็ปล่อยไปแล้วยังไงล่ะก็กลับบ้านมือ
เปล่านะคะ
ติดมือมาไม่มีปลากลับมาบ้างไส้นะคะรยาก็
ไว้ว่า
ทำไมเนี่ยไม่มีปลาอีกแล้วหรอ
ไม่ได้ไปอีกแล้วหรอรญาก็แบบ Road กดโรม
มากก็ถามทำไมอ่ะทำไมตกปลาไม่ได้ทุกและก็
ชาวประมงในเพราะภรรยาถามถามถามสุดท้าย
เนี่ยเขาก็เลยหลุดออกมาว่าเออจริงๆวันนี้
ก็จะปลาได้นะเอ้าแต่ว่าปลาเป็นปลาพูดได้
ตัวสีทองแล้วก็เป็นเจ้าชายเห็นแล้วก็เลย
รู้สึกว่าโอ้สงสารก็เลยปล่อยปลาอย่าปล่อย
ใบ
โหที่นี้เนี่ยหาได้ยินรู้และช่วยลิกกิ้ง
นะคะ
สุริยาเนี่ยอะไรคนดีก็พอจะเดาได้ว่าเพราะ
ภรรยาเหนือโกรธแล้วก็โกรธเพราะอะไรไม่รู้
อาจจะหิวหรือไม่เห็นปลาหลายวันก็เลยเดา
ว่าพอรู้แบบนี้เนี่ยจะต้องแบบ
แล้วทำไมไม่เอามาให้
คะใช่ค่ะภรรยาเนี่ยก็เลยแบบ
ปลาสีทองเป็นเจ้าชายมันก็ไม่ใช่ปลาธรรมดา
ใช่ไหมเพราะว่าปลาปกติพูดไม่ได้แล้วก็ไม่
ได้ตัวสีทองด้วยระยะก็เลยคิดโอเคพรุ่งนี้
นะออกไปตกปลาเหมือนเดิมแล้วก็ไปหาปลาสี
ทองหรือว่าปลาเจ้าชายแล้วก็ขอค้อนโอเค
หน้าภรรยาก็เลยบอกว่าให้ไปขอให้เราเนี่ย
มีเครื่องอะไรมีกระท่อมใหม่เพราะว่า
กระท่อมที่อยู่ตอนเนี้ย
มันเก่าชายค่ะชาวประมงเนี่ยเป็นคนที่
เชื่อฟังภรรยามากๆนะคะโอเคดี
พรุ่งนี้เขาก็ออกทะเลไปแล้วก็ไปร้องเรียก
หาล่าปลาเจ้าชายปลาเจ้าชายอยู่ไหนแต่ถ้า
ปลาเจ้าชายก็โผล่มาชาวประมงก็ขอเชิญไหมขอ
พรว่าเออผมขอกระท่อมใหม่ได้ไหมไม่ช่อง
เก่าเนี่ยมันเก่ามากๆครับ
ซึ่งเปล่าเจ้าชายก็โอเคอ่าพอชาวประมงกลับ
บ้านนะคะก็ไปเจอกับกระท่อมโต
อันนี้เป็นกระท่อมเปล่าไหนด้านไหนครับจะ
เป็นสิใช่ก็ไปเจอกับกระท่อมหรือว่าบ้าน
หลังใหม่ที่ใหญ่กว่าเดิมโอเคโอวันนี้หลัง
ใหญ่แล้วๆช่วยอันนี้คือหลังเก่านะคะ
หลังใหม่ใช่ไหมพันภรรยาก็อุดีใจมากๆแต่พอ
อยู่ในบ้านหลังใหญ่ป้ายนึงวันสองวัน
1อาทิตย์พญาครู้สึกแต่
ถ้ามันไม่ใหญ่เนี่ย
หึให้ที่ไหนกว่านี้อยู่กันกี่คน 2 คน
โอ้โห
ถ้าเป็นคุณนิคณบ้านใหญ่แบบนั้นน่ะคุณนิ
กับไม่อยากได้ใหญ่กว่าเดิมเพราะขี้เกียจ
ถูบ้านไม่จังเลยกับ
หัวหน้า Two  to เหนื่อยกว่าว่าหมู่บ้าน
เหนื่อยไม่เอาไม่ต้องอยู่แค่ 2 คนใช่ไหม
คะขึ้นจริงอ่ะชาวประมงเนี่ยเขาก็โอเคนะ
กระท่อมหลังเก่าประท่อมหลังใหม่อะไรก็ได้
แต่ภรรยาเนี่ยรู้สึกแบบไม่ได้แล้วไม่เอา
ไม่พอบ้านแล้วเนี่ยมันเล็กเกินไปและภรรยา
จะเลยบอกให้ชาวประมงไปขอพรกับปลาสีทองใบ
ให้เปลี่ยนโอเคไม่เอาแล้วไม่อยากได้
กระท่อมแบบนี้เธอนี้
อ่าโอเคก็เลยแบบขอพรให้ปลาเนี่ยไปบอกว่า
ขอเปลี่ยนจากกระท่อมขาบ้านนะคะเป็นปราสาท
โอ้โหโอแบบนี้เลยปราสาทใหญ่ๆ 2 คนนะอยู่
กันสองคนแต่อย่าได้เหยียบใหญ่มากๆ
ใช่ค่ะซึ่งปลาเจ้าชายก็ให้ตามที่ชาวประมง
ขอครับเขาก็ได้อยู่ในปราสาทเนี่ยใหญ่ๆ
ครับ
พออยู่ไปอยู่มาอยู่ไปอยู่มาก็เริ่มรู้สึก
แบบ
อยู่ในปราสาทใหญ่ขนาดนี้มึงจะเป็นแค่คน
ธรรมดาหรอ
ก็ไม่ได้นะโอเควันเกิดนี่ก็ไม่บอกว่านิ
สามีไปขอพรกับปลาใหม่ซิ
แต่ฉันอยากจะเป็น
ราชินี
โอเค
อยู่ในปราสาทแล้วต้องเป็นราชินีนะคะมันร
ยาคนนี้นี่ไม่พอสักอย่างเลยนะขอให้ค่ะไม่
พอแบบได้บ้านที่ใหญ่ขึ้นก็ไม่พออยากจะ
อยู่เป็นปราสาทก็ได้เป็นปราสาทก็ยังไม่พอ
ใจฉันจะต้องเป็นราชินีใช่ไหมคะเป็น
เป็นราชินีเป็นคนที่ไม่ใช่คนธรรมดาทราย
นี้ฮะเป็นปลาชินีน้องซึ่งพอเป็นราชินี
เนี่ยอ่าชาวประมงเนี่ยก็เริ่มรู้สึกแล้ว
ว่าเอ๊ย
ภรรยาเนี่ยถ้าเป็นราชินีแล้วก็คิดว่าก็
น่าจะไม่พอก็น่าจะขออีกขออีกขออีกไป
เรื่อยๆเพราะว่าคิดว่าภรรยาตัวเองเนี่ยมี
แค่ไหนก็ยังไม่พอเพราะเริ่มอยู่ไปเป็น
ราชินีไปเนี่ยภรรยาก็เริ่มรู้สึกแบบ
ไม่มีความสุขและรู้สึกฉันเป็นราชินีเนี่ย
ไม่พอชาวประมงเนี่ยก่อนที่ภรรยาจะขอเพิ่ม
กว่านี้มากไปกว่านี้ชาวประมงเนี่ยก็เลยไป
หาเจ้าชายปลาแล้วก็ขอพรเองไปหาหมอพรเอง
เลย
ทรายอ่อนขอพรอะไรครับก็ขอว่าก็บอกว่าขอ
ให้ภรรยาผมมีความสุขเป็นคนที่มีความสุข
ครับ
ใช่เจ้าชายเนี่ยพอได้ยินคำขอนั้นก็เลยเอา
ทุกอย่างคืนหมดเลยว่าจะเป็นราชินีอ่า
แราสาทหลังใหญ่ๆนะคะจากปราสาทหลังใหญ่ๆ
เนี่ยก็
เปลี่ยนเป็นอ่า
อันนี้ค่ะกระท่อมหลังเดิมโอเคกระท่อมเก่า
ๆหลังเดิมแล้วก็อะรญาก็มีความสุขแล้วก็
ไม่ขออะไรอีกเลยอ๋อโอเคใต้นิทานเกาะจบนะ
ฮะคูนี้แหละฟังแล้วใช่ไหมคะพรุ่งนี้คิด
ว่าภรรยาเนี่ยเป็นคนยังไง
คือคุณอิงไม่คิดว่าผ่านไปยาเนี่ยเป็นคน
เอิ่ม
คนนี้กำลังคิดว่าไม่รู้จักพอแต่
คุณจะคิดว่าเพราะเขาว่า
ได้ของมาง่ายทำให้ไม่ง่วงอ่ะไม่รู้จักอ่า
คุณค่าของของที่เขาได้มันก็เลยทำให้เขา
ไม่รู้จักพอเพราะคิดว่าเพราะก็อยากได้
บ้านหลังใหญ่อยากได้ประสาทอยากเป็นเสือ
ราชินี
ไม่ต้องทำอะไรมากแค่ไปขอกับเจ้าชายปลาได้
มาง่ายๆไม่ต้องเหนื่อยไม่เหนื่อยใช่ใช่
เพราะคุณนี้ก็เลยคิดว่าเขาไม่รู้เขาไม่
รู้จักคุณค่าของของที่เขาได้ทำให้เขา
เนี่ยอยากได้มากขึ้นมาขึ้นมาขึ้นเพราะเขา
รู้ว่าก็แค่ให้สามีเนี่ยออกไปทะเลไปหา
เจ้าชายปลาแล้วเดี๋ยวก็ได้แล้วทำให้เขา
กลายเป็นคนที่แบบไม่รู้จักขอด้วยไม่รู้
จักคุณค่าเหมือนที่ครูนิดบอกใช่ไหมคะ
เพราะคุณนึกว่าถ้าเขาทำงานเองจะเก็บเงิน
แล้วทำบ้านที่หลังใหญ่
กระท่อมหลังใหญ่กว่าจะได้มาเนี่ยเขาก็จะ
เขียนเราว่าเออมันนี่มันไม่ง่ายนะคะจะใช้
เวลานานเก็บเงินทำบ้านเขาก็อาจจะคิดได้
ว่าอ๋อนี่ไงคุณค่าของ
กว่าจะได้มามันไม่ง่ายๆมันเหนื่อยนะฉัน
ต้องทำงานมันต้องใช้เงินใช้เงินเท่าไหร่
จะไหมคะให้ตัวนั่นแหละแต่
ส่วนชาวประมงล่ะเออใช่พ่อพ่อขอแต่จริงๆ
พ่อเขาบอกว่าอยากให้ภรรยามีความสุขใช่ไหม
แล้ว
ทุกอย่างก็เป็นเหมือนเดิมภรรยามีความสุข
แล้วหลังจากนั้นก็นิทานก็จบหรอกครับใช่
ค่ะก็อยู่ด้วยกันในกระท่อมเหมือนเดิม
อย่างมีความสุขนี่จบแบบมีหน้าก็ไม่ต้องตก
ปลาแล้วไม่ต้องคิดก็ต้องจะออกไปตกปลา
เหมือนเดิมแต่ภรรยาก็ไม่ได้อยากได้อะไร
ที่มากและนี่ก็คือเหมือนกับพอใจแล้วว่า
อ้อมีบ้านอยู่มีสามีที่ดีมีอาหารกินพอ
แล้วไม่ต้องมีบ้านใหญ่โตไม่ต้องเป็น
ราชินีอย่าก็คือภรรยาก็มีความสุขกับสิ่ง
ที่ตัวเองนี้เออก็คือเหมือนกลับไปในชีวิต
เหมือนเดิมแต่แคบเป็นภรรยาที่เหมือนกับ
ไม่รู้ว่ามีเจ้าชายปลาให้ขอคอนอ่ะครับเออ
คือไม่ได้ใช่ไม่รู้ว่ามีเจ้าชายปลาให้ขอ
พรแล้วก็ไม่ใช่คนที่เอ่อโกรธง่ายเหมือน
เมื่อก่อนใช่ไหมเป็นคนที่รับเออคือเมื่อ
ก่อนอาจจะเป็นคนที่โกรธง่ายเพราะรู้สึก
ว่าทำไมฉันถึงเป็นคนจนทำไมฉันถึง
เหนื่อยขนาดนี้เหมือนกับไม่ไม่พอใจกับ
สิ่งที่ตัวเองมีอยู่ก็ไม่มีความสุขใช่
มั้ยแต่พอไปเราแบบดีใจกับสิ่งที่เรามีมี
ความสุขได้กับสิ่งที่อยู่รอบๆตัวผมคิดว่า
ณ 1 ยังไงเอ้อสัตว์พี่ถ้าเมื่อก่อนพออยาก
ขออะไรก็ขอได้ขอได้ใช่ไหมคะกับกลายเป็น
ว่าโอเคก็เราก็มีบ้านมีทุกอย่างจะเลยไกล
ทำให้ทำให้เขาก็กลับมามีชีวิตเหมือนเดิม
อยู่กระท่อมเก่าๆได้โดยที่ไม่ต้องมีบ้าน
ใหญ่ๆเพราะว่าสวยแค่สองคนนั้นคราวจะมี
บ้านใหญ่ขนาดนั้นไปทำไมเออ
ใส่แทนนะถ้ามีบ้านใช้
เราก็เหนื่อยแทนนะที่บอกว่ามีแค่ไหนก็ยัง
ไม่มีความสุขอ่ะเออ
แล้วก็นักเรียนหรอคะนักเรียนฟังแล้วคิด
ว่าภรรยาชาวประมงเป็นคนยังไง
คิดเหมือนเรามั้ยน้องก็คอมเม้นท์บอกเรา
ได้นะคะได้และ
ก็ก็วันนี้หมดเวลาแล้วใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะเดี๋ยว
เรามาเจอกันใหม่ในวีดีโอหน้านะคะโอเค
ครับอ่ะ